so the question the day today is I
forgot there's that part too right now
okay just comes out naturally I don't
plan this um obviously good morning
believe nation today's message is view
failure as an experiment over to you
James Altucher I had failed and
succeeded and I started over 20
businesses 17 of them failed and we
unfortunately living now in this culture
that almost glorifies failure like it's
we're supposed to be so happy oh fail
fast fat it's like this failure
pornography almost that we just like we
just worship people who fail and then
somehow succeed but I could tell you
like failure is really unpleasant and
it's much better to view it as a much
better to view it as like an experiment
like Thomas Edison you know Eden fail
10,000 times when he's making an
electric light bulb he just experimented
and he made an electric light bulb we
don't consider that the guy was was
lying on the street about to kill
himself on the very first try he tried
10,000 times so what do you think I i
love the perspective that he took uh it
it's kind of true right like a lot of
messages are right now you know what
failure is not a bad thing you want to
enjoy fair you want to love pain like
it's almost like promoting sort of kind
of a masochistic kind of mentality of
like pain is good for you and so the
example in the previous video of you or
if you're watching all these videos one
of one of them was we invest a lot of
time a lot of you know capital into this
new thing for the business for Toronto
damn salsa to work the back end it
failed super frustrating not happy with
it but it's like what's the lesson like
what are the good things that we can
take away from this feature you know
this product that we try to bring in
that we can use to improve you know
toronto sales and it also helped us
understand a little bit about our own
business in our own needs right you know
as we went in we thought we this is what
we needed but we realized we need
something different so it's funny i'm
going to use a batman
it was I think was by Alfred he said why
do we fall sir so we can learn to get
back up something like that I might be
butchering it so don't hate me for it I
wanted to save god i found
why do we fall
so don't we head learn to pick ourselves
up I think that they took the lesson
that you learn from you don't have to
enjoy pay you not enjoy failure I mean
you have to get up and try again because
if you if you choose not to learn
something or you or you just to focus
too much on the pain then like what's
the point like what's the point of going
through all that or even trying
something right so you just need to be
aware of what can I take away that's a
golden nugget that I can take somewhere
else this is an interesting one for me I
think a lot of people are attached to
failure a lot of people are afraid to
start and for me it's just it's i think
people are just too attached to the
outcome than the process I enjoy the
process even if it's a failed outcome I
still enjoy the process you know the
project that we talked about fraternal
that's also that failed that's eating up
a ton of time that's putting those three
months behind where we're supposed to be
I still enjoy the process of thinking
how can we make our school better and
we're still going to learn some things
to that that will make the school better
even though the end result was
frustration and you know students not
send up as many as we should have I
still enjoyed the process and I'll do it
again you know it will hope they have a
better result because they do it smarter
the next time I look at the youtube
videos I enjoy the process of making the
videos you know it's Wednesday afternoon
we're recording these I enjoy every
Wednesday afternoon I make it cuz I want
to make it i make because i love making
it we've changed a lot of the videos in
the series some have been added some
have been removed the ones had been
removed i don't see is this failure that
i can't get over that was this huge
mistake it didn't lead to the results
that I wanted or maybe I just grew bored
of making those videos and they were
doing well but I like the challenge of
the process of making the videos better
and trying new things and so I think
when people get too addicted to the
outcome then you see failure as a huge
thing and I don't I don't celebrate
failure and I also don't get hamstrung
by it I just don't care like I like the
process of making I like the process of
doing it and I don't get so attached to
the outcome that it holds me back from
doing something else so I don't know
let's just not care about failure let's
not celebrate it
let's not be held back by it why do you
care just go out and do learn and get
better and and express yourself through
the art that you're creating that's
that's for me you know I could have the
greatest results but if if making these
videos was a negative for me like oh I
have to go in and record my videos right
then that then it's never going to do
really well so you have to love what you
do and enjoy the process and not just be
addicted to the outcome I don't know
that's what I took from Earth maybe
that's not the message but that's what I
took from it so the question of a today
is share a lesson that you learn from
one of your failed experiments I like it
leaving the comments below will join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso